far cry 5 has a release date February
27th 2018 and with that announcement
comes a trailer which just dropped today
I'm here to go over some of the things
you should know about in his open-world
shooter for our overall far cry 5
thoughts
stay tuned to Lucy into Moore's video
discussion on our YouTube channel while
you're there give us a thumbs up and
subscribe if you're unfamiliar with the
Far Cry series it's a first person
shooter known for its charismatic and
insane characters endless outposts and
the limitless opportunities for
improvisation while you try to survive
from what we've gathered so far far cry
5 follows the specific formula started
by Far Cry 3 the series is also known
for being set in exotic environments
which is why Far Cry fives location of
the American state of Montana is unusual
and as such captivating the region is
hope County and Awards sinner added to
the welcome sign helps set the tone a
cult known as Eden's gate has imposed
their will and influence on this land a
calming yet nonetheless unsettling
monologue comes from Father Joseph the
leader of the cult my children I'm here
to tell you that suffering is a choice
and you can choose a better path the
trailer is littered with his followers
many of whom are roaming hope County in
pickup trucks converting the locals to
the cult often forcibly this one woman
doesn't seem thrilled about it is she
being baptized it seems more like a
drowning the Bible wielding preacher in
that scene gets considerable screen time
in this trailer with the seven deadly
sins carved onto his skin he looks like
a formidable henchman but based on what
we know about father Joseph's family
he's neither the eldest son Jacob or the
youngest John the sins also appear to
factor into the game's plot as evidenced
by this brief gluttony murder
coincidentally it was the first murder
shown in David Fincher's 7 another
mystery character is the
african-american woman who appears
briefly in the action scenes she could
be part of the cult or she could be the
custom protagonist you'll be allowed to
create or is your hero the
driving her into a TV speaking of
vehicles far cry 5 carries on the series
tradition of giving you a number of ways
to get around we spotted helicopters
pickup trucks tractor trucks and
off-road vehicles and while not featured
prominently in the trailer we can
confirm that you can pilot planes in Far
Cry five including crop dusters and
fibia s-- aircraft two planes capable of
pulling off bombing runs the plane in
this scene looks like a P 82 defiant
it's a plane that features a ball turret
which implies a push towards the co-op's
entered campaign other little things we
spotted the name Falls and possibly a
town within hope County a rabbit's toy
in a car local businesses who are
affiliated with the colt the Bible quote
John one for which we learn says in him
was life and that life was the light of
all mankind the song heard during the
second half of the trailer which is
called when the world's on fire
it wouldn't be a true rural County
without animals and this trailer reveals
that you'll encounter dogs bulls and of
course bears we have it on good
authority that you can enlist attack
dogs as sidekicks who are skilled enough
to grab weapons from your enemies and it
wouldn't be a proper far cry without a
cast to support your protagonist the
bartender with the shotgun
that's Mary Mae this guy that's Nick
Wray and the pastor's named Jerome for
as much of a threat
Eden's gate is in Hope County these
three aren't going down without a fight
for more insight into these characters
backgrounds you can check out the
individual character vignettes at
GameSpot right now this place is ours
[Music]
expect even more far cry 5 info to be
revealed in a couple weeks at e3 thanks
for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]